es ist passiert in einem labor wurde ein
molekül erzeugt das sogar stärkere
kräfte hatte als ein schwarzes loch es
hatte so starke anziehungskräfte darf es
alles um sich herum zu recht warum
unsere erde trotzdem noch existiert und
wir nicht vor den stärksten kräfte
zerrissen wurden jemals mit licht
erzeugt wurden jetzt endlich zum science
fiction dazugekommen
es war der absolute wahnsinn wie kräfte
die erfolg wurden waren größer als die
eines klaren schwarzen loch mit zehn
sonnenmassen und das im labor das
erzeugte molekül übte eine so starke
kraft aus wie es ein schwarzes loch
nicht vermocht hätte was war passiert
rudenko von der kansas state university
und seine kolleginnen und kollegen
untersuchen strahlen sie wollen wissen
was strahlung mit molekülen macht dafür
schossen sie einen energiereichen
röntgenblick auf ein jod methan molekül
die wirkung war für das musik molekül
fatal
zunächst wurden ausschließlich die
elektronen des ewz getroffen
das methan reagiert überhaupt nicht auf
die ausstrahlung der röntgenblick
entriss dem note fünf bis sechs
elektronen die durch die photonen des
witzes ganz aus dem molekül gerissen
worden
dann kam eine kettenreaktion in gang die
fünf- bis sechsfache positive ladung
risiko centris den anderen atomen in dem
molekül die elektronen die dann auch
durch den röntgenblick aus dem molekül
gerufen worden
am schluss war das molekül 54 fach
positiv geladen nur noch acht seiner
elektronen behandeln
zitat das ist unser wissen die höchste
in organisationen die je mit nicht
erreicht worden ist so koautor robin
sandra vom deutschen elektron
synchrotron desy
es hatte damit absolute superkräfte
selbst ein schwarzes loch mit zehn
sonnenmassen hat eine geringere
gravitation als die elektro magnetische
anziehung dieses molekül zitat sei ein
echtes schwarzes loch könnte durch seine
gravitation auf eine elektronik eine
vergleichbar hohe kraft ausüben egal wie
nah man dass elektronen an das wort noch
heran bringt was erklärt lang war vom
baby dieses schwarze loch ist aber gott
sei dank eines das gravitation ausübt
sondern lediglich elektro magnetische
anziehung auch die wird nicht so dass
jetzt alles in der umgebung angezogen
wird und am ende ein echtes schwarzes
loch entsteht das gegenteil passiert
diese riesigen kräfte zerstören das
molekül fort und das schwarze loch ist
verschwunden
jetzt wollen die forscher noch stärkere
kräfte erzeugen in dem größere moleküle
beschossen werden
wir können also auf den nächsten rekord
gespart
zwei mal sehen was da passiert wir
halten euch dafür hier natürlich auf dem
laufenden
drückt mir hier ein abo auf auge
unvergesslich den aufstieg locker denn
nur dann verpasst er auch kein video ja
ihr geht es weiter mit einem mysteriösen
schwarzen noch dass die theorie über
schwarze löcher um wird dafür einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten gesang bleibt
dran